one life hi everyone
welcome to Monday melee I'm your host
Aaron Blair along with me is Beth
murasky she's afraid she fears her life
Jason omalley back in the corner creeper
Hey he can't he's too far away though
yeah I can't even I just wanted to get
up close to everybody I hope everybody's
have good weekend
y'all gonna have a good week this week
today we're playing Dark Souls 3 again
I'm very nervous and if you watched last
time but I basically just ran as fast as
I could do this bonfire and demolish a
lot of chairs what was that
can you beat up a lot of chairs you
showed the chairs that's right do we
have a furniture count I think yeah it
was around 40 somebody asked for the
next clue this game rose we shot a
clueless game around Friday but that
one's not coming out we're actually
gonna shoot another one before that one
comes out you know what for people who
talk [ __ ] about the fact we're always
playing new games we played an old game
for that clueless gamer so I don't want
to hear it um no one so far has said no
one so far said the fact I'm in the
cameras face I guess maybe this is the
way we should play this is how it is
with Beth really small yeah look at this
way I just poked a Beth in the face
Benjamin Meyer says he's gonna do the
deathcounter do we have the furniture
counter from last time oh research in
the last guys maybe your look maybe
you're wondering now what's going on
with our set today we've got a little
fan back here and some fan art not made
by this family fan ah we've got a really
fun Conan Korea live Q&A tomorrow at
11:30 Pacific time that's our time with
Conan O'Brien
Jesse Gaskell Jose Arroyo the writers
who went to Korea and because our Korea
episode aired on Saturday and it's going
to air it again on way
today in case you missed it so there you
go you can watch it all you can watch it
on Tim Helga comm slash Korea which you
should you know Beth look yet for the
thing in the Oh ryo koyuki it's midnight
at your place damn damn damn damn damn
damn look at us just spinning around
okay here we go so let's do it so the
last time I don't actually remember the
controls here but here we go did we oh
yeah that's right there was a huge
dragon I tried to kill us I'm gonna turn
this up a little bit cuz I need to hear
the sounds of my death
okay I'm Ally's gonna research the
situation the chairs the chairs and all
that stuff
alright I don't truly remember oh that's
right B runs okay can't go up this way
clearly we got some souls pillage
remains titanite shirt
why aren't the vids in Canada I'll tell
you why the vids aren't in Canada
because Canada we are on CTV there I
believe and you can actually I've done
this go to the CTD website and watch
clips there that's a bummer I'm sorry to
hear that
but they will be up event but we'd love
we love everyone to watch our clips it's
really not enough gonna and I'm from
Michigan which is basically Canada so I
feel your pain that's right
Coenen right now Bader girag is meeting
with the segment producers for today's
show he will not be here Monday melee
but we are hoping a certain special
guest who beth keeps emailing over and
over will show up i'm very excited
[Music]
that's right dizzy sorry say my name
Alex you Axl there you go or were you
just singing along to like Beyonce say
my name say my name when no one is
around you got it kill some carts oh
come on
Jesus say my name it's called yeah Dark
Souls ignition alright let's go over it
let's go over the freakin controls again
here what are the controls are we gonna
do anything with overwatch and that
comes out next uh I would love you some
of the overwatch I hear it's gonna be
awesome
can you guys email the over Watchers
who's overwatch Blizzard right why are
people excited about overwatch what is
it should I should know about overwatch
I've destroyed two furniture things by
the way that's seven more up to nine on
furniture count boy that's eleven twelve
oh we have it up there Costa Rica
represent death counter again we're
getting it we're hitting it together
Ames we're getting it together as well
as the furniture counter am I supposed
to be going this way and can I creep up
on this guy can I do a little creep
oh it's a blizzard game that's why I
didn't even know it's their first giant
game in a while ouch it's their first
new IP that's not wow those are words
that deserves a while hey Holly he'll
listen from south-korea put the face cam
at the top right so we could see your
items and stuff Roger that thank you
face cam is going in the top right
appreciate it
no wait a second remember that time
where there is that dragon and he just
completely left me up cuz that's about
to happen again I feel okay nope nope
nope nope and I'm dead oh I'm dead I'm
not dead haha I'm alive guess he's about
to be dead Oh me apparently yes Jesus
Christ no here's the thing what are
you're a zombie you don't have a lot of
musculature I can't believe that guy
with the armor can move that fast this
game is totally not realistic it's
ridiculous not realistic move furniture
killed we're up - what was it before do
you know for 33 plus 9 I can't do math I
killed 9 pieces of furniture so far
we're also keeping track of how to make
me feel better about myself about my
game playing or keeping track of how
many pieces of furniture in this story
which by the way I'm just gonna predict
it's gonna be a lakhs I'm pretty uh I
didn't sleep well last night
no people I think bleh did you go to
create didn't I did go to Korea I was
there I was there in Korea it was
awesome although it was winter so that
wasn't so great
yeah it's snowing because it was freakin
cold no wait there's a dude around here
somewhere he came after me before I saw
a guy walk out this door where you at
where you at door Walker
well this castle looks the same kind of
a lot more guys in here earlier weren't
there did I make that up I felt like you
yeah you had to battle off oh wait you
know I have to go I have to go grab the
souls that I had before I'm gonna kill
this dude kill them all just like that
great Metallica song oh I think I'm not
oh I just killed three more pieces of
furniture I think that I'm not doing a
good job in terms of knowing how far
away I could strike I think my range is
pretty good here all right dudes gonna
come up here got him oh dude let's get
those souls recover lost souls boom
souls retrieved
that's right slide on down see what
happens down here nope see yeah yeah
it's called a shield [ __ ] best defense
is a good offense and best offense is a
good defense everybody knows it Oh
anyone even better offense is my frickin
axe alright here we go man all these
people praying dude and it can help you
oh here we go
oh Jesus Christ alright run away run
away run away let's get out of here
let's get out of here Oh God come on oh
come on
what giant lizard man okay Dylan
appreciate the freedom oh geez I don't
know what that means but thank you
Maurice from Lebanon kill it I'm trying
Joel all right here we go you know what
I do I need to kill all these guys again
the answer it friends is no the answer
is we just run by him Wow I mean except
when we get tagged doo doo doo look at
me just running by everybody nope nope
nope big old nope nope nope nope nope
nope no no no
no no no dissent let's just take our
sweet time descending oh man I'm on the
bladder this isn't gonna go well
this is okay how do i oh man I fell down
don't leave me just nailing those dudes
though how I drink my potion again oh
there we go
ah yes that's right bring it back bring
back
hashtag demon make America potions again
okay you know what's gonna happen
recover these Souls I'm just gonna run
away this way doo doo doo doo doo don't
need to fight that lizard guy we're
gonna run away oh he's back he's back
he's back lizard guys back don't fall
off the thing lizard guys back and some
guys back we died we died fall damages
that hurts bad fall damages gnarly all
right all right we survived lizard thing
hey there lizard guy can't get me ha ha
ha ha huh see my name right I'm
subscribe unsubscribe then I don't I
don't cater to your demands
let's subscribe do it I don't want you
around here I don't I've seen people's
names you know what I'm killing some
furniture and I wish that was you there
we go
oh you hide run before hey now I'm a
fired come on dudes oh I got to drink
some of that potion wait around the
corner come on
oh look at this juking kill this guy
kill that guy please this game is
ridiculous Juke him yep juked him uh
how's that reload speed there whoa son
alright there we go alright now this is
the part of the game I would like to
save but I can't so instead I will
descend the slider to my death and
there's a okay this guy is this guy's
gonna kill us
yeah remember the other guy was
arresting and they turned into a giant
like snake monster
Beth Beth Beth says POTUS hey tiny Leah
Escobar good to see you de l'arche
what's up Dolores right now it is 12:12
look at that furniture count though well
we only want confirmed kills so I just
slice that dude part here's the guy I'm
gonna kill kill this guy gotta kill this
guy don't worry about it yep yep oh
that's a there's a big guy over there
never seen before now what are the
chances I could just take this big ax
and this guy is not gonna come after me
probably zero you know when you see a
little tab below like this or there's
just chaos and you see a guy pacing back
and forth Dead is what that means
alright this is awesome you're awesome
Chris moschini
official smudge what's up oh oh look at
that huge guy that's really scary that's
really scary
don't come this way though please man
I'm gonna get so [ __ ] killed
look how big this guy is can I hurt him
or something can I take something out of
here you know I could use some of these
swords it was but this guy definitely
didn't do enough squats look at that no
definition that in the glutes uh hey
thanks Dakota you're the best we got a
couple coolest gamers coming up with
it's gonna be very fun right now all
right
let's go yo yo yo reluctantly bothered
what's up hey could you move the chat a
little bit over I can't see that yeah
it's okay if you block what we're doing
okay
what's up Titan hundred forty one good
to see you all right guys I'm going for
it we're gonna first here's our strategy
first of all we wrote as fast as we can
pass this guy impossible second strategy
that guy it's such a big ax he's
carrying that's so he's definitely
compensating for something don't you
think talk about a second small penis
situation
it's just it's huge man this guy has
killed a lot of dudes I'm not going for
that soul over there thank you instead
we're just gonna kind of scooch around
him you know a little scooter ooh all
right
oh man that went extremely well hey damn
it I knew that went too well yeah man
you constantly got to be on your garden
ah Jesus
these guys just sneak up on you okay
yeah this doesn't look like a trap at
all definitely not a trap nope no trap
here oh don't go down there
also that oh that guy we're gonna have
to fight that dude at some point smooth
moves next yeah go scoots Magoo since
you [ __ ] is dead scooching the Gucci's
all right let's get you know what take
it blossom steam okay all right what do
you think we go here let's cancel man
these people you know the people I
flipped this house could really do
something special with this castle I
feel like you know oh I love blind
corners love blind corners let's kill
this frickin guy
oh oh but I perfectly timed my role I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead oh I'm
dead I'm so dead there's so many guys in
there you know what we didn't do we
didn't follow our role which is run away
from everything we got out do did fight
the dude
okay here we go guys
stick to the plan run just like in real
life when you're talking to a girl run
as fast as possible
speaking of girls let's forget this guy
run past him run past him run past him
though run past him on our stuff now
we're stuck now we're stuck now we're
stuck we're stuck now we're dead now
we're dead we're dead we're dead
we're dead we're dead that was
embarrassing
you know these people have a job don't
these people go to work what are you
hanging around a freaking castle for go
to your barista job take off your
cosplay uniform and go to your barista
job
ah hey your graça good to see you what's
up Edgar as gaming today how's it going
what do you guys think of the Korea
episode by the way okay we wait for this
guy to go away
that's our souls we're gonna we're about
to retrieve these dudes but get off my
jock
how about you no game I like get off my
jock souls 3 oh this is locked that was
don't go that way where do I go before
I'm gonna get out of here
oh oh we didn't go down here before
didn't we no oh we're so close oh my god
no we're not dead we're not dead Jew
come Jew come back up the stairs you
know what now they're all clustered down
there I can use like a gun or like some
grenades or something where did we go
before [ __ ] oh we didn't even come out
here why don't we do this we go down the
stairs we don't do that oh yeah take
your time
oh god this guy again Jesus I get it
you're angry about something and I just
run forever oh boy oh now we got this
dude now we got the guy on the thing
who's coming up the stairs please jump
off the ladder
come on oh my god
[Music]
anybody have any tips run run run get to
the choppa hey thanks site appreciate
the clueless gamer love I had a fun you
guys should check out I have fun
interview with Game Informer magazine
about clueless gamer that was alright
you know what I wanted to run by I
didn't want to have to kill you but now
you just got me smashing furniture again
that's what I'm gonna call making love
to a woman from now on smashing
furniture it's pretty romantic right I'm
gonna start using also the that button
were you oh wait you know what maybe we
should go down here right there's nobody
down here let's go down here you know
what we haven't gone down here Oh
O'Malley you're ready to count up some
furniture smash it that's five six I'm
going to know what that is at seven
eight look at this this is great I'm at
the table yeah I gotta bring out the
game genie oh god why did I look away
and now there's a guy here with a giant
thing oh man ah note to self don't go
down the ladder
the thing is though is it better to go
across there across the rooftops because
there is that big slimy angle how do I
just get out of this world let's go to
Disneyland
Grayson the robot yes a Dark Souls 3
they have a furniture kill counter it's
my favorite thing so far about this game
ok that guy can just go that way nope
see you later
first running or just running running
running run I'm pretty serious then
against so a lot hey god damn it dude
uncool I'm gonna use one of my beers
smashes more stuff over pay attention o
malley I want to get that furniture
count up I want to get to it I bet we
could get a thousand today our goal is a
thousand furnitures I know that's not
how it works
furniture kill count is wrong I want my
money back since Mirek all right we
going outside to be going down to fight
the dude in the basement what do you
think we go outside and we go down to
the basement I'm gonna take a swig of
seltzer where you decide oh I think we
actually have to go down to get our
souls this is the this is the [ __ ]
about this game is you have to go how do
i just send faster to get your souls you
have
[Music]
go go go go go go run oh man now we're
in this basement I don't care about the
throwing knife
Oh God you know what's bad is trying to
block on the dudes behind you all right
let's kill this guy
let's do where's yeah Jesus I can't kill
the barrels right now Malley I have to
kill this guy I don't have time to kill
the barrels I'll get to the barrels in a
second oh wow Jesus oh my god this guy
sucks my oh I should have gone for the
barrels yeah
Aaron furniture killer Blair no see now
this sucks cuz now we have to go back
and kill the guy with the axe to get our
freakin souls back alright you know what
you know what I dead I hate you that's
just such a cheap all right here we go
alright we're gonna be smart this time
unlike all the other times you ever
danced the devil in the pale moonlight
we'll look at these moves though boom
dang Oh see that's what God just when I
get cocky then another do comes out of
nowhere all right it's kill sit barrel
we gotta keep this merchant count up
that's five four all right here we go
can I just send a ladder fast or anyone
know how to descend a ladder not at the
speed of my grandmother my grandmother's
dead by the way so it's gonna be Souls
sneak over here alright okay I get it
Oh aren't you big and strong he's
helping us I've managed to really nope
yeah what now
ya missed me yep now what yup not so big
and powerful Olli are you now Skeletor
hold B to get down the ladder faster
thank you time to celebrate but but but
the birth is this game at Benny Hill
music cuz he needs it for this better
that's good
oh I'm just going buck wild oh this is
the greatest day my life okay here we go
all right now it's yeah that's polluting
now we're just gloating okay here we go
all right wait we haven't been in this
room yet oh you know what I should do is
drink some potion okay I'm gonna drink
another potion okay we're feeling good
looking good looking real good
thank you Vivek I appreciate that it's
hard for me sometimes to look over at
the chat because then six dudes come out
of nowhere and just like you know like
stick knives up my palm dude just dude
so high over here
yo bro how's the scene what did you know
fractals are like forever oh you got a
bomb well that's not cool
hey man fern oh yeah that's the best
really you know the best kill is when
you kill something and then you know you
also kill some chairs too cuz you know
[ __ ] chairs they're bad G it's a trap I
knew it I knew it's a trap
yep and that's a terrible way to stab
someone Oh take that hood off your head
it probably smells like crap whoa okay
here we go here we go let's go down this
hole you know I I can't I got it well
hold on good furniture break I gotta say
you know this might be a little bit
better than their rooftops and I know by
saying that I'm totally screwing myself
shields up
shields up here we go here we go here we
go eyes on the prize and the prize eyes
on the prize is there like a bonfire
somewhere here and a dude in his cell
there's a bog he threw a bong at me so I
catch it and smoke it now see this feels
like a bad idea to let this guy out oh
it's locked
you're telling me I don't know it's more
unbelievable the fact that it's locked
or I can't destroy these things it's
just above my head I can't
I've never played blueshift shady what
is blueshift oh you know what they're
gonna make me do you know what this game
is totally evil they're gonna make me go
all right
they're gonna make me go back on the
rooftops now I gotta go back through all
this [ __ ]
if these guys respawn I'm an out of
major issue with this game
I hear people they don't sound happy so
I'm going to ask you about our special
guest star for the twitch I haven't
heard back should I text them here I'll
take care of the Beryl's how you kill
the barrel that's hot everything's
locked oh I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
send a quick text didn't get that text
in
let's see here all not
okay hold on a second
I think they're ignoring me because
that's what happens yeah Beth why don't
you talk a little bit about the awesome
Korea YouTube cue a live that's gonna
happen tomorrow well 24 hours 23 hours
the YouTube live Q&A with Conan O'Brien
and writers that worked on the Conan and
Korea episode will happen live on
YouTube
probably and also on Twitch probably at
11:30 a.m. tomorrow Pacific time
well done on this couch in front of this
fan and fan er that's right okay here we
go
we got to go back through this [ __ ]
I'm unhappy about this I can't tell you
the ways that I'm not happy about this
I'm so unhappy that I have to backtrack
that I'm not even destroying furniture
that's how unhappy I am you've never
seen me this upset there all right half
light blue shift is a standalone
expansion pack of the game half light
it's very short but pretty fun
interesting now I've never played
half-life I know a bad person it's
locked just said to break one barrel you
know just for luck all right dudes here
we go I'm not excited about this this is
not gonna go well all right
so we got to go out and face the lizard
man so really I shouldn't go down I
should go out this way because I can't
go down next time I die which will be in
about ten seconds
I know there's another dude I knew there
was another guy right behind me I'm wise
to your tricks Dark Souls 3 you guys
always put another guy right there
always that dead dragon of it smells
terrible all right now I know how to go
down a ladder fast nothing can stop me
okay that dudes about to turn into a
lizard man so what are we gonna do let's
get a game plan here we're gonna run
across the thing and go down and then to
the right oh it's so creepy this is
terrible this is why I don't want to go
to Europe was kidding I love Europe Oh
God
wait where are we gonna go we're gonna
hide right here okay then descend
descend descend Please Please descend
please descend thank you thank you I get
very polite let's kill some barrels I'm
nervous I'm just nervous so I want to
kill some barrels oh this this room
looks real bad oh this room looks real
bad
oh there's guys behind me I can't do the
barrels right now got a run yo boom
you're carrying a lantern there you were
I thought you were way scarier than you
actually were all right okay we're okay
we're okay guys we're okay oh oh god
there's a big guy there oh no oh no
don't come in here please we got some
pots dude oh there's a guy behind the
pots luckily I killed him let me just
get these pots though okay oh man I'm
nervous nervous guys oh I need a bonfire
all right where did we go where do we go
I'm really antsy oh that guy's so
proudly Oh
Barriss Key says chill
okay we're going up we're going up let's
go let's go let's go let's go okay let's
go in here let's go in here oh there's a
guy I've seen this guy before though 4/5
of it where's the other guy I know
there's another guy in here
there's always another guy where's the
other guy there's no other guy ah
there's the other guy there's always
another guy always another card so many
guys all right we got some Farrell's up
here though take care of you no my job
is never done
tell me Farrell died oh there's like
I've been killing there's four more
barrels
I got a there's chairs and a pallet
could somebody please mod this game so
it's just about destroying furniture
yeah she's like an enormous barrel comes
man yes Conan came back from Korea
just barely not his mind well I don't
play half-life get Black Mesa it's a fan
recreation of halfway with updated
graphics whoa cool oh it steam
controller yeah well thank you
RIPD barrel said show ass you feeling me
all right here we go dude I think we're
gonna try to kill that dude do you think
oh I'm totally getting ignored Dierker
King yes I'm always talking sorry no hey
I killed some girls by falling out of
that was fun alright there is do we
think we could run past this guy what do
we think run past who Matthew sure sure
art says hey Beth Beth your turn to play
can't wait to see me take on a boss yeah
I can definitely
we was there guy over me how many I'm
gonna jet buy this guy I think right
these boots were made for running
everyone loves Beth run from him
run run kill him kill him all right I'm
gonna run from him but I'm gonna wait
till he's walking away to me like kind
of scoop by oh hey all right
scooch Macoutes let's go no we've never
sooc we couldn't scooch
we didn't scooch it all but we did dodge
him let's go let's go let's go let's go
run run run run oh there's a guy there
that's a guy that's a dude all right all
right
scooty scoot scooty scoot your sins oh
god this guy's definitely chasing
scooch-scooch-scooch oh there's more
dudes oh I don't have time for the
prayer oh that's a dog there's a weird
dog there there's a weird dog I got
killed all right we got it we got a why
is this guy's so much bigger does that
mean we're fighting all these children
that guy it's like weirdly tall [ __ ] man
we got so far that time are you all
right did I get an extra barrel yeah
there's no way we're getting past all
this there's just no way it's not gonna
happen but let's try it nope nope miss
me I'm running past all these dudes
we're talking we're doing another speed
run speed run where do we go again here
on that side we go this way nope miss me
oh [ __ ] I fell down oh I fell down
here's this guy I hate these guys
damn it that guy's got a bomb but I
throw your bomb I'm on fire
I just put my head all right later I'm
out of here by the way I want those
barrels counted that was like four
barrels now I gotta climb up this well I
don't have any soles so there's no point
if you if you don't retrieve your souls
then you don't have any souls right and
then those souls are lost so I think I
just lost all my souls just fine I don't
care about souls what does game I think
is two barrels I think you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna practice cuz I'm
gonna definitely get killed by this dude
right now so when I meet this guy later
I'm gonna practice it so I know what to
do right now their nose Oh see it's the
they bring their little pals it's not
why this guy hang out with is to the
barrel gods do not spawn I'm good at
killing furniture that's true the
puppeteer I should shave off my beard I
have before it's horrifying I never yell
I just want to make it to another
bonfire wherever that may be
all right I'm gonna kill oh hey got my
souls
0 souls retrieved yeah
Oh
how do i wow that guy just burped now I
just want to kill this guy oh I'm so
important once you get a new Cape Cape
looks like [ __ ] hey what's up Elvis lot
good to see you backstab the gold monkey
says that's good cause I still think I
should have been a night instead of this
warrior guy but you know what this is
the diver get the Diceman cast yeah miss
me What's Up now [ __ ] oh right in the
back you
I'm breaking barrels I want those I want
those counted all right well that's one
way to get out of there oh great now I'm
done with this dude again please get out
of here let's climb up this thing hey
push this kind of fun
aha you fell down hey yeah come on see
what's up now ah screw you guys I'm not
here alright well that worked well oh
don't fall down there though please
there we go so polite when I'm nervous
okay
there's these guys here comes this stood
up the ladder hey there's guys behind me
what the hell my nope don't care you
know what these guys should fight each
other man I do like games like where the
guys kind of were like different groups
like go against each other you know like
I'm trying to think like grand theft is
kind of like that Oh
there is a lot of screaming happening
look you're just trotting over by later
evasive maneuvers
Wow Jesus I have an arrow in my back how
did that happen oh no this this place is
full of dogs and stuff so I'm gonna run
up over this way oh oh
use the opportunity to get our asses
kicked whoop eat that guy screw you how
do I use my fire bombs anyone know
here we go here we go wait a second
don't I have like 16 fire bombs why does
it look like I have no fire bombs what I
know I've been picking up fire bombs
can they kill me when I'm in this mode
probably an inventory here we go here we
go here we go here we go what is this
action I don't care about this use use
no not use oh Jesus isn't there just
like an equip that's how the F do I
equip the dumb light oh I love to know
all right now what's up all right we got
a dog all right let's do a little recon
here I'm seeing five barrels in that
thing
four barrels that's nine barrels I'm
seeing three more twelve barrels okay we
are inspired by that I've never faced
ormstein and smoth demon soul bosses
they also something they can all own a
deli ornstein and smough slop smock
delicious deli meats all right there's
two dudes down there and a dog and that
dog looks underfed so oh you know what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna use the fire bomb
thing
oh wait well I got a tool belt that's
cool equipment here we go
okay nope what I want is inventory got
it now let's see show it if I switch
it's not doing it there's gotta be a way
to do this right
Wolverine is cool Beth doesn't play in
ten seconds I'm gonna jump off a cliff
with a letter in my pocket dude I can't
believe you live near a cliff that's
gotta be a beautiful view all right how
do we how do we do this anyone now show
item info yeah I would like to use this
please oh I see I guess we can do it
like this
whip it down there let's wait till
they're kind of all we're gonna wait
till they all kind of get coal s there's
got to be a better way to do this right
I don't believe it equipment last two
rows choose Bob
hello I'm doing it the other way I
should choose the
well I need to use in the house Oh
and here they come let's go
awesome man that works so well didn't do
a goddamn thing he's it again ready oh
hey Doc well that looks like he's just
trying to scratch its own back hey I
killed the dog that's pretty cool great
now there's only two giant dudes with
huge axes what is that thing
golden pine resin the hell's that flies
lightning the right hand weapon why am I
not using this alright I don't know how
to do that Howie
man I want to use that lightning thing
I killed two furniture Rios's thank you
Oh Oh someone's gonna get destroyed what
I'm now lightning oh there's so many
more guys down here there's like four
guys oh my god I went down there and
there was like 16 dudes hiding another
thing I should
anyone know how much further yep that's
right
yes yes this is the first time why do I
not do I look like an expert does it
look like I've been playing my whole
life I mean I could see that being true
alright we're gonna go out this way okay
about this we don't care about this guy
flat oh Jesus you're coming down a
ladder that's just ladder seat hey what
did I tell you guys about ladder seat
someone's standing at the bottom of a
ladder you got to say hey you gonna say
Tallyho here I come yeah exactly like
top points kill him kill quick return to
that thing kill em quick
I'm out pray to you bring it
I'm gonna kill this guy
that's my new thing Tallyho good chap
bacon salad ladder safety it's all about
ladder safety here we go
new objective kill the salamander man
that can be done first we kill this
freaking [ __ ] I hate this guy I hate
that guy every time he gets people just
a little bit just a little just annoying
little frickin thing now I'm gonna kill
this guy cuz you know what I don't I
don't like your attitude I don't like
your - dude yep
you know what I think you're a bully
damnit
I don't like the cut of that guy's Jim
I'm going after him
Wendy Dark Souls become resident evil
mat of seven I don't know cuz I've never
played Dark Souls before or this game
though I will say I've always been
against Dark Souls because people go
it's so hard it's so hard and I was like
that's dumb that they would make a game
so hard like how is that fun but this
game is super fun I mean really their
genius was to add destructive furniture
you could destroy because that's really
where the that's where the money is for
me I mean look at this oh god look at
how much fun this is but like an artist
like made every time so yeah and I'm
just destroying the [ __ ] out of it here
we go
come in Oh
oh yeah sorry yeah that's all right
see here all right so ah came out of
nowhere
not our special guest Dave Myers is a
special guest
that's our laser your tongue I can't
block two people at once I'm dead that
Myers to me oh that's why I did room I
know beautifully I did feel really bad
so we're surrounded by the offices of a
show called the real yeah they're all
super nice really great people and you
know a lot of times we'll shoot stuff in
the studio like tomorrow we've got a
YouTube Q&A about Korea at 11:30 a.m.
Pacific time I bet they'll hit you with
the link you guys should all watch Conan
will be here with writers and all that
stuff we shoot stuff in this room a lot
of times and this is just kind of like
an office we've made into a studio so
when people are noisy which they
frequently are around us it's really
annoying like we're trying to shoot
something for workaholics guys and like
you can hear other people on the mic and
so it's really annoying but a couple
weeks ago with Brent Brendan Brendan
Shaw Rob Schwab was here from the
fighter and the kid and we were being
super loud and these people were doing
auditions next door and then yeah they
came in and they were like hey I'm sorry
could you guys be quiet and and then we
were like I was like I can't I can't be
quiet I'm so sorry
and I felt really bad cuz like the shoe
is kind of on the other foot at that
point I just I felt awful but I also
wasn't quiet so I guess you know kind of
what go
look at oh look at this
oh Jesus God this guy's tough man yes I
felt that I don't have an indoor voice I
don't even have an outdoor voice I have
an outerspace voice it's carries in
outer space
what up ride good to see you Richard
bate gaming what up does that mean dick
bait gaming I don't know all right
yeah I will say it but anyway it's my
earlier point this game I don't know how
I would describe to someone why this
game is fun but it is like just getting
murdered over and over I don't know why
that's fun why is it fun
that feels like a good accomplishment
when you do beat a level Oh
[Music]
me yeah he's good
that guy this guy can eat a dick right
there Oh
Jesus Christ
he always I'm just trying to have
encouraged you
what's his what's his deal man how could
I
what's his guard about oh that's where
he [ __ ] me that's where he gets me
right there
[Music]
I can't back I can't back out of his
range I think I got to go when he stabs
me I gotta go to like I get maybe I
gotta move inwards run towards him right
before it roll towards him right before
he hits right I think part of the thing
with this game is a lot of these guys
yeah a lot of these guys have huge huge
like sweeps of their sorts but if you
can get inside the ark you know see I'm
learnin slowly you can get inside the
ark you're all good
I'm doing a great job killing these
things god damn it [ __ ] you
sorry oh man
huh okay I'm sorry what whom I mean they
met you in Toronto in 2010 and you took
a picture together someone named pics or
it didn't happen pic cert didn't happen
Toronto that was a fun time you know
good I was my first travel show or they
must have in the tour I could've been
the tour or it could have been
late-night also here comes this a-hole
running up the stairs bring it bring it
I'm dead David oh oh no sickle grind I
love Toronto I just I just hate that guy
I just gotta kill this freaking guy
screaming so you want to swear way more
than I really should be swearing go
ahead throw your [ __ ] little [ __ ]
go ahead yeah how does he still get
through am i just attacking at the wrong
time all right I don't care about that
guy all right where's our little friend
you know what I'm gonna warm up on these
boxes mal you getting this I'm warming
up on these boxes I'm sure pin my ex by
the way my axe is like almost dead what
happens with my axe dies
[Music]
all right here comes shits McGee yeah in
your [ __ ] face damn it
eat a dick oh I hate you oh god damn it
ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok
ok we're gonna kill this guy we're gonna
kill this guy we're gonna kill this guy
and I avoid I am going to celebrate now
this game has just come down to me
versus this night ok ok
it's exactly like King Arthur alright
first we kill this [ __ ] guy ok there
we go
I'm sorry for the language bearing [ __ ]
my people don't like that but then again
I see it it's also addictive you know
this game used to be played well on deck
oh there's so many guys down there holy
[ __ ] what we're all those guys coming
from there he comes here he comes
come on charge it up
Oh God
yes I just need to be if I get close to
him what can you do to me oh that I just
roll up into his crotch oh no no no no
oh God oh one more hit I would have had
him ah one more hit I just did so slow
at the axe just like uh what am I like
ninety years old in this game freaking
hit him with the axe do you just like a
quick you don't this game needs it's
like a little like like a little like
like a little you know I'm having a
stroke no you know like uh I need just
like a little jab I need a jab it's
everything he does he like is like all
right I'm gonna hit you get ready
Oh like just like just pop him man
you know I think I kept like a beat this
game if I was this guy and I had a
switchblade I could beat this game cuz
all these guys are like oh yeah I'd be
like stab just ship him I just need like
a ship Matta of seven I know I have
different speed attacks but here my two
speeds all right bro I got this speed
and then I got this speed those are the
only speed attacks I have
I don't have any other weapons let's not
even talk about that giant dragon that's
over there like it looks like it's
orgasming do I have any other weapons
how do I switch my weapons around all
right I only have these two weapons bro
oh wait maybe I should wait hold on
maybe if I do oh no wait a second
Hey look hey I got these other I got
this other weapon
look at this I got a whole other weapon
wait a second how do I quick question
but I would really love to use of these
fire bombs how do we do that like this
or something or down here oh man oh dude
oh [ __ ] is about to go off oh my God
look at this
Hey look I got a hole all this sword so
quick oh man guys I just discovered
something called the inventory in this
game pretty incredible all right me and
this little broken sword oh and
firebombs oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] already
you guys are dead you're so dead oh
you're so dead
all right yeah you don't have the stats
to wield it what now what now what now
oh he fell down the thing look how scary
was it me your mom doesn't have the
stats to wheel it oh yeah exactly it's
all about thing no it is about to go up
here's why I'm just gonna rail this guy
with fire bombs here he comes oh oh this
guy's no idea what's about to go down
Oh what now what now where are you at
where are you at
yeah what's that oh no oh that sucks for
you
oh that sucks oh Jesus hey hey not hey
that's not fair oh no that's
another guy you know that's what I get
for me I deserve that
I deserve that I deserve that I'll take
full blame for that I deserve that
I deserve it's always you know I guess
it's my hubris I just think I should
have been I should I should have been
more careful as what I should have been
you guys you know gotta watch your back
always yeah all right let's cut this guy
up slice and dice a little knife fight
in here this guy is not dying this is
not it
this weapon sucks by the way oh my god
I'm about to get just how about a fire
bomb to the face all right here we go
all right you know what I'm learning
this was all right there we go this is
the better weapon okay okay here we go
all right
oh [ __ ] you know what I should have done
I should I should Eaton's a potion
before him at the fire bomb boom oh
let's get away though let's get away
I need that potion now I need that
potion please oh wow he just stabbed the
[ __ ] out of me oh I'm lucky that was
like virtual reality cuz it was like Oh
[Music]
worst Yago you have the dexterity yeah
to get damaged okay fair enough
but now I will say I got these fire
bombs and they're going quick but I'm
doing pretty good so far with them this
guy comes at me come at me bro
boom all right dead all right we got
some trousers I'm gonna O'Malley hit
this is for you a Maui yeah for all time
see that yeah old times better times
okay all right here we go all right here
we go
all right no not a time we don't have
time oh you know what new idea I'm just
gonna whip a bunch of stuff down there
at these dudes you know what this is a
good idea
yep really glad I did that
good job dude oh man that was except a
good idea wasn't that a good idea guys
well not a good idea
yup this is a great idea loving this
good job Blaire let's just stay to the
corner let everyone just piss all over
us God the people on the outside oh yeah
that's true I am screaming really loud
and I just said stand in the corner and
piss on me sorry I forget we're kind of
in a wooden Cup remember what I said the
whole thing about us being a workplace
what's it well I'm so curious what's
gonna happen when the axe die when the
axe goes dead yeah I'm talking to you
so mad so anger I would be too oh
there's out of you
can I just whip things at him oh this
guy can be just a huge dick
oh they'll stop you don't fire - okay
let's knock it in the corner let's not
get it kill him yes he died okay okay
keep our heads let's keep our heads
let's keep our heads about us keep our
wits about it I'm just gonna whip this
one at this guy to keep our wits about
us yes Oh your face tonight oh man
can I do anything to this guy no that
killed him just like oh look at that
blood where he fell oh man oh man drink
some get drunk all right oh do we think
is that the game basically I think we
well we got some Souls now oh man things
are looking up all right here's the
problem there's like 50,000 other guys
and a giant scary dragon right there Oh
God why would I go this way I don't even
remember where I'm supposed to go at
this point are we supposed to run across
something what happens now I'm losing my
mind oh you know what I think we are go
down here I honestly was so concentrated
on that night I don't even know what to
do now let's kill this guy
oh Jesus there's a lot of guys down
there
whoa that's real bad oh no I had the
wrong thing
Wow they never gave me a chance to
defend myself and I blew it
can I just like please just kill a dude
without also getting hurt every time
my mom's don't know this guy's got a
long thing this guy's gonna you know
what let's shoot this guy jus come to
him
let's go chook City I don't know if I've
been down here oh no I have wait this is
where oh no we went backwards this is
where the dragon is why am i running up
here this is a terrible idea I've ever
seen in my life
why did I go this way this was so stupid
this is so dumb why did I do that why
did we go back to the place of the tribe
oh we're supposed to go down the stairs
I got too caught up in that guy all
right we shouldn't even fight this night
then because we're going backwards
we ran past that guy before that's not
helping us
would you two kill that other dude again
I'm not I'm not killing that dude again
we've done it we did it
let's back here though in this corner
can we hide back here alright forget it
you carried away with the Jukes yeah
you're right I got to Juke tastic what
is gonna happen when art acts runs out
we're totally screwed by the way
make quick work of that guy these
barrels man this game is like Groundhog
Day
if Groundhog's Day took place in hell
you know just got to do the same thing
over and over 50,000 times that guy can
go [ __ ] himself
come on oh yeah oh god fine
oh man that's graphic guys please ah
sorry I slept with your girlfriend Jesus
Oh soon as the bond for another pair of
the axe thanks mimics alright you know
what the why all right let's hit the
we're gonna we're gonna repair our axe
so we're gonna do exactly but where do
we go to prepare is this it the Firelink
shrine I think it is see what's
happening back at the UH the old
homestead you know learn my stamina
management ooh drascalo
that's a good call easily wielded axe
that I know this game had jokes in it
that's funny
yep all right well how's the furling
shrine going there's the girl that
touched my darkness earlier housing hey
hey what's up hey thanks appreciate it
oh you know what I don't have any soul
so I don't know if I can get my stuff
fixed oh this place I forgot there's so
many candles in here
allergies go crazy oh is this the place
we couldn't get out of before yep we're
we met hit this man this guy's oh yeah
that's the guy looks like he's
constantly trying to take a poop all
right repair prepare weapon reinforce
weapon oh I can't do anything perfect
man good dude are we on the same side or
not man come on just fix my stuff for
free all right whatever
well back to the battle with my broken
ax hey lady if you want me to go kill
all these guys you gotta help me
oh you think darkness is your ally I
could call her what do we is this for
our tower no long Aquafresh 193 needs a
grade-a sugar mama well what are you
doing you got to put in the work bro if
you want a sugar mama you can't just sit
back and wait the sugar wait for the
sugar mama to come to you I'll get some
souls you Group improve your weapons at
the titanite that you found okay Oh anal
shredder says or is it anals redder
anals redder we're an ultra nicer
here we are mama mama Frances please
kick me the ball so I want to buy this
game dude I have to say I used to hate
Dark Souls but I never played it and now
that I'm playing it I hate it but I love
playing it it's super fun it is really
fun it's just really hard but then you
do kind of get better I mean make a good
point Beth it's like oh great
especially when I'm just getting railed
by a demon and there is a sense of
accomplishment like when I'm just
throwing all this furniture and the
furniture does regenerate by the way if
the first you didn't regenerate
I wouldn't like this game here yeah but
I guess it yeah half the fun more than
that but there is there is a certain
sense of of accomplishment
when you when you kill things because it
is hard anything worth doing is worth
doing well alright here we go
you prefer blood boards gothic miss heal
can make a second one about I bet
they'll make another like your weapon
repairs are you ready
oh that's cool oh yeah now my repet now
my weapon is totally back I knew you
were coming out of the woodwork knew it
I knew that was gonna happen where does
it guy turn the lizard oh we're not
there yet
all right here's the lizard man over
here man I wish it was like a aah are we
gonna fight lizard man are we just gonna
let lizard man live ah can we fight him
no I don't think we can I think we're
not good enough he's gonna die let him
live for now lizard man loser may didn't
even turn into lizard man
Oh spoke too soon come feed the foot
lizard man's annoyed Wow
[Music]
I gotta learn how to dodge man I get my
dodge skills O'Malley these are for you
for more furnitures you know I say yeah
I agree
bees these creatures should stay dead
look at this view though it's pretty
very pretty
oh this is where the big that big guy is
that's all right now that my axe is
alright I kill this guy
what oh I can fight going near that
dragon breath so good look at that very
hairy hairy good I don't see is that big
guy over there maybe he's not there this
time do they do they regenerate randomly
or no they're in the same place every
time
oh you magic Castlevania like this says
Reba nature that's good call oh there's
the big guy oh that guy looks so scary
I'm gonna stay out of the way mr. tiny
penis over here this giant thing that is
just such not a good weapon to carry
around that's gotta be so stressful on
his back dude
[Music]
should be waste scarier than it is good
thing this guy doesn't look behind him
he's got tiny little feet so he's got
like a sighs where's probably size four
or five way less scary all right
miss me and I who else is here who else
is here I knew there's another guy
there's always a guy
there's always another guy alright I
think we're okay oh we haven't gone down
this way to see what could kill us the
thing is now we're so far in I just want
to save my game oh there's another one
of these douches all there's two of
these dudes just down there hey oh he's
coming to get you oh oh man don't come
up this way please
alright what's our move here what do you
think do we run okay there's a douche up
there this is like douche Gardens yeah
except with douches alright I think does
that look blocked over there I can't
tell
[ __ ] douches everywhere alright yeah
I've been trying to lock on I've been
trying to do that
just imagine you'll get good one day to
fight these nights like there are
nothing I hope so huh alright I can't
run through that doesn't look like it's
open over there what do you think I
think that's open right I like that game
because you can't really see douche
Gardens in nature girl
alright I'm running through ready we're
gonna run through douche Gardens we're
doing it let's go nervous nervous
nervous nervous nervous nervous oh we're
dead run run run run run run run run run
run run
run-run oh no this looks really bad oh
this is bad maybe he's friendly
you know what the douches didn't follow
me in here so this is totally bad what's
about to happen well we've only got
about 10 more minutes in the stream so
Drake him up okay okay nervous okay
it's real quiet in here
can I like save my game right now dudes
should I just draw all this furniture in
here or is that just gonna make this
person angry hold on let's work just
let's clear some stuff out oh man this
is like this is a good 20 or 30 right
here
this dude gonna be upset that I'm just
trying on this stuff he probably doesn't
care right what do you think Q's pues at
11:00 here we go
there is no save says Matt's Wiegel oh
so I got to run through all that oh wow
oh my god this is great this is like an
extra hundred yeah these are nice chairs
although they are kind of coming apart
yeah they're really easy
maybe my feeling really dry in here you
know who can I go up the stairs Oh
what's up special guest I'm just at 7:00
the end so no no that's right welcome
Robert George slansky in the house this
can't be that interesting I just heard
you guys talking about the furniture
falling well see now let me ask you a
question Jordan what is your what's your
opinion on furniture do you would you do
you like assert oh this is this game is
called dark souls 3 by the way this is
where a night
everything is do you like fantasy stuff
or not so much yeah but I've never
played a fantasy game I think the last
game I played with RBI baseball in it oh
that here all the people on the 10 you
can say hi to people in the chat there
holy jesus they're mostly nice people
are free yeah everyone's really nice oh
my god everybody loves you looks like
people from all over the world and
fascinating yes what countries you have
represented here uh every orden what's
to know what countries you guys are in
tell Jordan tilt your over don't just
throw Cubans does that mean they're
Cuban or they just blurting out people
yeah people love you by the way follow
Jordan on Instagram at Jordan slansky
someone wants anywhere a wig
you can't take this - oh my god they're
a bulgaria barbados or any other job you
fantastic
I don't see why work there's a power
here I don't know how we accept lawyer
yeah I don't know yeah incredible
worldwide audience ohs Portugal very
cool that's right you guys you have
Jordan asked during the question Jordan
are you a trial amazing Oh somebody
likes your hair there we go fascinating
are you carrying any preparation oh you
know what one thing we've been doing
lately is Jordan's been reviewing
products and we begin to ask yonyx
that's true we got some uh some Norelco
shaver x' yeah we haven't got any
preparation-h wipes yeah but I'm I'm I
can't wait for that day our staff came
in the next day completely careless I
don't understand exactly
Bosnia wow these countries are
fascinating Georgia Canada
great good stuff so what is this game
now so now we're playing Dark Souls 3
you played RBI base but you're not a big
ideal game guy though are you well I was
at the time of RBI baseball and I'm
guessing this audience may actually be
familiar with that reference that's
right oh wow oh look at this I don't
know we've reached the end of uh
we've reached the end of something which
I'm not sure what this is sorry now
Jordan you travel a lot is there any
place that you haven't gone that you
would like to go I'm embarrassed to say
I have never been my list
oh so that'll be my next trip the
problem is I always try to coordinate it
in spring time to see the cherry
blossoms and that's what kind of speeds
me out there's inevitably in spring time
some things oh that's true we don't have
because we don't really get to choose
our time off yeah yeah yeah that's right
oh my god well now we're playing I don't
think I'm gonna fare too well in this
guy yeah the we we actually saw Lord of
the Rings together the first Lord of the
Rings
yeah was that the one where you showed
up in shorts and I was no that was star
on travursel movie that was Jordan is
one of the only people on staff to
actually see my legs but yeah most
people haven't seen my legs for good
reason yeah I don't know what I was
doing but I showed up and I was sweaty
and we watched Star Wars together that's
interesting so that's bored of the four
yes and I'm not sure exactly what he's
doing or what were supposed to be doing
and there are always like these ethereal
names for the fantasy characters they're
never named Mike Walker right I know
that's the thing they're like Craig or
something right exactly exactly we don't
care about your legs I'm not gonna show
my how I died
so this venue is a combination of
fantasy video games and questions and
social communication its social yes its
social communication and fantasy video
games ISM combines and someone had the
idea we loved both of those things
separately let's put them together right
exactly what images yes we kind of
thought it would be fun exactly you
could really add a social element to
almost anything you could absolutely
yeah I mean that's the thing is like you
could come on here and answer questions
all day long or you could come on here
and play video games all day long we
have combined the two sure ten that's
what kind of twitch is right George's
life but somebody it's a social
experiment that's right all right well
that's gonna do it for today guys say
goodbye to Jordan thank you for stopping
by George oh great
this is man by the way I think it we've
been doing for twists for how long over
a year it's it's been almost two years
and every single week I asked her to
come on and this week I'm actually
shocked I'm actually speechless
I didn't you called me on my bluff and I
didn't know what to do
yeah I'm not sure why I'm here I don't
know either I don't know either anyway
say goodbye to everybody see you later
guys All Right see you guys next week
you